all right here we go here we go we got
this story from cnn ooh cnn ron de santa
signal support for stripping disney of
special self-governing status as feud
escalates because apparently the only
republicans who actually do anything are
in florida yeah it's weird so basically
disney has this this uh a special thing
going back to 1967 a state law that
established the reedy creek improvement
district giving disney the power to
establish its own government in central
florida he basically said you know what
why should we have companies that have
this special privilege right which is a
smackdown because
desantis said disney went too far
i think disney went did go too far
because after the backlash
let me slow down disney refused to call
out the parental rights an education
bill which the left calls don't say gay
which makes no sense because that
doesn't even make sense um and so they
refused to do anything disney employees
walked out some of them got arrested for
child sex trafficking whole other story
but around the same time mind you and uh
then disney decided they were gonna be
like oh okay okay yeah we oppose that
bill and we're going to see it defeated
in the courts and then desantis is all
like yo
what does disney have to do with
the people passing legislation that's
gone too far now you got republicans
saying that they're going to be going
after disney and stripping away their
rights and good
i'm loving it because these leftists
abigail disney actually she's the great
grand niece
of uh uh of walt disney himself she's
the granddaughter of uh roy disney who's
co-founder
and she was saying like
these far-right groups are trying to
rule by minority and they're they're
saying insane things referencing chris
ruffo and all that but she says it's i'm
happy to see the right finally going
after the business sector that's for so
long propped them up or whatever and i'm
just i'm just sitting here watching like
you know did you think disney propped
the write-up well
these companies are all woke that's why
i'm like what do you think's going on
yeah the the the institutions are all
woke leftists critical race theory etc
the right has not been supported by cnn
i mean look at let's just say starting
in 2015. how about that but we know it
goes back further yeah i i think well
i'm a little bit torn because as an
anarchist i like the idea of a company
being able to have its own government
within its own jurisdiction but i am
ecstatic
that if either the political parties and
hopefully both alienate from corporate
america which has historically been i
think to a large extent you have these
kind of chamber commerce mitt romney
republicans have been a thing in the
republican party especially after like
republicanism was defeated by fdr you
kind of had these you know weak
republicans who were kind of like you
know suburban shop owner middle of the
road kind of types
and they kind of made apologies for
corporations just doing really
unconscionable things so the fact that
republicans at all are coming to
understand which democrats many
democrats for a long time understood
that corporations are not your friend
that if a corporation were a human being
that person would be a sociopath um and
the more distance there is between
politics and corporate america the
healthier it is for everyone involved
including corporate america i think i
think corporations could also be uh
likened to the borg oh yeah
so you know i like to point out the borg
in star trek is like communist they're
this collective they just grow and
expand i think that's a better way to
view it because it is a it is a system
of governance the borg it operates in
but corporations are not too dissimilar
and that they absorb other companies
they grow expand they're authoritarian
and single-minded yeah profit is their
motive i i worked for disney as a temp
for their pocahontas premiere in the
park in central park and speaking of the
borg they had like a dress code you
couldn't have piercings you couldn't
have like dyed hair like there was this
very specific list of things about your
appearance that you had to have even
just working for that one day for them
where was it disney world or central
parks they had pocahontas the movie had
the premiere in the park was a thing
i like my age now i don't know all about
this it just seems so weird that any
corporation would would have its own
government on u.s soil that doesn't seem
right to me so it's weird isn't it yeah
it's very very strong yeah it's it's
similar in anaheim with uh was it
disneyland or whatever i don't know
where is world is in florida in florida
and uh so when the when people were
rioting down in anaheim over i think it
was a blm thing or something like that
and like the police came out
in force
more than i'd seen in most places and
it's because well now you're coming
after a major corporation in their
corporate profits so once the once the
once the riders and you know protesters
started getting close to this bridge
that brought them close to disneyland
whatever the cops just went off they had
boken you know a boken is it's like a
wooden katana and they were on horseback
with boken what where where the cops get
those from i don't know
like the mulan exhibit it was it was it
was a weird thing to see cops on
horseback with bokken but it was also
kind of cool i'm like these are these
are like samurai warriors i guess it's
the weirdest thing to me okay i don't
think i i don't know if they actually
hit anybody with them but that's what
they're for they're for
striking people i got a prediction i
think that this is gonna go to the
courts or do whatever disney's gonna
fight it for a while then they're gonna
agree and be like okay whatever and then
they're gonna start lobbying other
states and be like who wants disney
world and then california is gonna take
it you don't think so i mean the cost of
moving that thing would be insane
um i i think they i think it's i
disagree i think it's more that they
have to publicly make a show fighting it
but then if they lose they could be like
well we did what we could yeah so a lot
of these corporations don't have the
spines they look like any person will
take as much space as you give them but
as soon as you put your foot down
they're more than happy to you know kind
of roll over like a dog and you put on
something they make a really loud noise
and then wrong i wanna i wanna make a
point for mr mouse here you you have
this famous quote about police
uh what every cop is a criminal well no
a more a more specific quote that a lot
of people say
i don't know which one you mean about
killing kids oh there is no law so
obscene that the police would not be
willing to enforce it up to it including
the mass execution of innocent children
yes um i think there's something similar
for uh corporations oh for sure i think
it's fair to say that there is there is
no um
path to profit so obscene that a
corporation would not pursue it up to it
including supporting the the pedophilia
and grooming of your children well i
mean we see it in like like like uh like
mining and you know in very poor
countries and uh like was it tropic um
was it dole or
chiquita yeah chiquita banana banana
republic yeah i think yeah that's where
the term comes from i believe so uh you
know again i i think one of the things
that corporate media does in dividing
people to right and left democrat
republican is that if conservatives or
republicans hear a leftist argument they
dismiss it out of hand but i think it
will behoove them to listen a little bit
more to some of the things that the
wrong people are saying because
oftentimes there's a colonel truth to
them and one of them is that corporate
behavior especially internationally is
often completely unconscionable well i
think
i saw this with uh with the rise of
trump when i was in florida or at his
rallies
regular people told me they weren't
republicans i remember this one specific
moment i was in a flo i was at a florida
a fort lauderdale rally and i was
talking to a middle aged woman and she
was like i've never voted before i'm not
a republican so you know i'm just here
because trump's saying things that i
like and i think that's what the
republicans didn't like this insurgency
of regular people so trump brought this
populist wave in and now it's no
surprise there's popular support among
the conservatives on the right to go
after woke corporations because regular
people don't like their kids being
screwed with whereas previously the
establishment republicans were very much
like hey man the businesses you know
are hooking us up don't don't get in the
way similarly with democrats but you
know they do different things playing
catch back and forth trying to you know
say what they need to say to win now
you've got people who are like i don't
care if you're a corporation or a
government if you suck you suck well
look at it this way just to add to your
point to agree with your point when you
think of someone from kentucky you think
of the stereotypes think of the bad
stereotypes think the good stereotypes
whatever you think you're not thinking
of mitch mcconnell it's impossible to
think of kentuckians and then think that
mitch mcconnell is the guy in washington
who represents what kentucky means it's
an absurdity yeah really
michael oh a pizza arrived
this is courtesy of john schnatter's uh
papa john's michael screamed and stomped
his foot and said if you don't have my
pizza i'm not doing the show that's
right it's starting to smell good in
here look at me i'm shaming
first of all this was put in front of me
by some racist in the studio who thought
that it would be funny that's so crazy
not racist if you're not human oh my
gosh wow
because he's a leprechaun right right
right
but uh but but also you can't be racist
against white people i'm pretty i'm
pretty sure i'm pretty sure youtube
allows that right irish people weren't
white until being white meant you had to
apologize for being white no he's
absolutely right there was arguments
including in america in the early 20th
century that regarded in some cases
irish people are as part of like the the
black uh population you want to hear
something interesting you wanna hear
something so uh where the the stereotype
of the drunken irishman comes from
is drunk and irishman let's be real bro
we're not gonna lie about ireland yeah
exactly
check this out
we're not gonna pretend yeah let's just
go with it you don't scare me outside
like we're not gonna pretend that one's
not we're the universal truth yeah
you're trying you're trying to see you
see here's the thing
anyone else
no not yet maybe after the show it was
in the in the turn of the century when
poor irish immigrants were struggling or
homeless they would pretend to be drunk
so that they would get taken to police
stations where they would get a food to
eat a place of sleep yeah and british
people actually have a substantially
higher rate of drinking problems than
irish people it's not only well the
british people have more of a problem
with it but they don't do it as much but
they're uh they do it more like thaddeus
wrestle in his book reading history
towards the united states talks about
this also because you had all these
super waspy factory owners you had all
the irish people came over they did
their hard work then they went home and
they ran drunk and these wasps who had
the protestant work ethic where you
thought working hard was inherently
moral and relaxing was somehow
inherently sinful and something to watch
out for they were flipping out they're
like look at these guys are lowlifes
they're degenerate they're sub-human
they want to go out and get have a good
time but as a result of those drunken
immigrants a lot more people started
having less work hours having to pay for
overtime because wait a minute if those
lowlifes are getting so why am i not
that's how it works you're saying the
labor movement wasn't a bunch of like
proud leftists raising their fist
there's a bunch of drunken irish
a week i'm supposed to be there what am
i supposed to drink
but he had i mean that guy you're
channeling i'm assuming your grandfather
has great great great grandfather he has
a point no it's true uh i studied
guinness the history of guinness
basically the dock workers would make
the beer or whoever was would make the
beer and then they'd give all the good
beer away for the irish they didn't have
any money so they'd get scraped the
bottom of the barrels to drink make the
beer out of that goop and that turned
into guinness which is my favorite beer
person oh blair blair white is in the
chat blair she said what up damn tim
pool's dad will not stop talking
he's got a lot to say i hear he has a
book coming out too how strange speaking
of how's the book coming along um
oh sorry i caught you in the middle of
this bit of a feast
this is a live show we can talk later
i just passed 150 pages uh it's probably
going to be 280 maybe 300 so it should
be done not long i have one tough
chapter left um and then it'll be all
smithsonian it's called the white pill
do you feel like you're getting
white-pilled as you write it no uh
because i'm writing about atrocities
that are being done to millions of
people including children uh i as i've
mentioned before i've been crying a lot
but this is the kind of thing
where when people read it be like how
have i ever been told this yeah this is
about the thing all right this is like
are some of these things too spicy to
give us an example or well i'll give you
one example this is a very easy one so
i'm writing about the soviet union in
the 1930s you had this big series of
purges right so you you kill the dad
right because whatever dubious reason
then the wife is arrested because she is
a wife of the enemy the people that was
the law and she can't even say i'm
innocent because you were married to him
now that kid has no parents overnight
they're an orphan they're beat up at
school because you're a kid of the enemy
the people and people who your family
was friends with couldn't take you in
because why are you taking in this
daughter whose dad was a spy supposed
spy and now you had a rash of all these
kids killing themselves and they're like
what are we gonna do about these kids
killing themselves so this is the kind
of like logic that happened in the
soviet union and these atrocities that
the fact that i'm like the only one
talking about this is really disturbing
to me and when you have the new york
times saying this isn't happening this
is all anti-russian propaganda thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there
you